Okay, let's start with the basics!
Emil, could you pass me a ball?
Level 30
That's not the trick
Good one!
Thanks!
There we go!
This is how you receive your own serve
That was a roller!
We got it!
Guys, you know what to do!
Help us reach 2 million subscribers!
There!
Nice!
Not bad!
Thanks
3 targets, 3 serves
That's one way to do it
I think I'll go for this one
Curve shot around the wall
And onto the cup
So the doctor told me not to move
That's not a problem for me!
It's time for the final trick!
Behind the back
No look
360 spin
Counter smash
Let's do it!
Did it go in?
Yeah... I think it did!
What!?
Remember to hit subscribe
And shout out to That's Amazing for this video idea
Go and check out their channel
Until next time!